right are we ready to
start okay welcome everybody this
session is about audio programming uh in
sear uh it's a topic that I'm uh very
interested in uh it's a real privilege
to be able to speak about it today just
quickly introduce myself uh my name is
Mark Heath uh I'm a plural site author
I've created over 20 courses on plural
site three of them are about audio um
nobody watches those but most of them
most the other ones are about Azure and
microservices and that kind of thing um
because my day job is working um with
Azure um building software for the
police and um the re probably the most
relevant thing for today's talk is that
I'm the author of An Open Source Library
called n audio which attempts to enable
you to do audio programming on The NET
Framework and so this talk is kind of a
bit of a story really of how I came to
create an audio and some of the
challenges that I faced along the way so
we'll talk a bit about some of the c um
aspects of it and I'm hoping I might
even at the very end have a time for a
very short demo um so let's dive in
because there's quite a lot to cover and
the story starts actually in the last
Millennium how many of you are old
enough that your career started in the
last Millennium and back back in the day
we would typically use a variety of
languages so I was doing C C++
programming but I was also using things
like Python and Visual
Basic and the idea was that each
language was good at different types of
thing and of course um C is a compiled
language that means you compile it into
machine code whereas some of these other
languages are what's called interpreted
language languages and that means that
as you're running your program it's
being your source code is being
converted into machine code on the Fly
and so the general understanding was
that if you wanted fast and often with
audio programming you want your code to
run very fast then you should be in the
world of c and
C++ also if you want it to go low level
if you want it to call um Windows uh
apis or if you wanted to communicate
with uh devices you would want to be in
the world of c um but of course the
downside of c and C++ was it gives you
many ways to shoot yourself in the foot
and
so often we would do as much as we could
in the interpreted languages um because
they did nice things like abstract the
operating system away and allow us to do
what we called rad rapid application
development but it was about this time
that I stumbled across Java sort of the
very end of the 90s and Java was
interesting because it didn't fit very
neatly into either of these two worlds
um Java basically you compile into bike
code which those how many people here
are net developers so you'll be familiar
with Intermediate Language it's a it's a
similar basically the same concept
really and you compile your code into
bik code and then a virtual machine in
this case the Java virtual machine and
the Java runtime environments we run
that by making use of the Just in Time
compiler so it's actually compiling your
code as it runs but it's doing it in a
more efficient way than typically the
interpreted ones will do because once
you've compiled um part of your code you
don't need to re recompile it to run it
again it also came with a slightly
different approach to garbage collection
or to memory management using the
garbage collector and that's going to be
very relevant to us later on and so I
started using Java and in my mind it was
kind of still in the slow category you
wouldn't dream of doing audio
programming in Java and then I came
across this project called Java layer
and what Java layer is is a fully
written in Java decoder for MP3 files of
course this was the late '90s so all of
us were ripping our CD collections to
mp3s and playing them on Winamp and so
MP3 was all the rage and what really
impressed me with this project was not
only could it decode MP3s to PCM but it
included a player so it could play them
in real time um and Java had got the
rappers in a package called Java x.
audio that could write to the sound card
and so this kind of blew my mind I was
not expecting um Java to be able to do
this and actually this project is one of
the first ones I converted to net um and
it's available um on GitHub if you want
a fully managed MP3 decoder I've
Rewritten it um well it's been Rewritten
three times time since I initially did
it um but it's available at n layer on
GitHub and of course not much later net
came out and the thing I liked about net
was it was a much more windows friendly
um development environment than Java um
Java was very much
um very much more in the Linux world and
when you built an application it didn't
even look like a Windows application so
I was very interested in um
in net and it came with multiple
languages it came with v you could
program in vb.net which um was similar
to VB but all the VB6 programmers hated
it uh you could program it actually in
Java in visual jsh did anyone use that
I'm probably the only person I I
actually converted that Java layer um to
net using visual J but Microsoft kind of
got in legal trouble and that died there
was also managed C++ where you could
write um net applications in C++ and in
theory get the best of both worlds but I
I found it felt more like the worst of
Both Worlds I I found it confusing to
use but of course C has become the
flagship um language of net and when net
first came out um you could download it
but you could also fill in a form for
Microsoft to post you the net um beta uh
on CD and because I didn't have a very
fast modem I opted to be posted the net
beta and the first thing I look for is
where is the audio support where is the
net equivalent to Java x. audio and to
my disappointment there was absolutely
nothing no audio support and I thought
maybe Microsoft would uh Rectify that
but basically they've they have never
really done it maybe not until uh 2016
actually so I decided I'm going to start
my own um open source project it's going
to be called n audio and my goal is
going to be to make rappers a two goals
really one to make rappers for any um
audio capabilities in Windows so
anything that windows can do with audio
I wanted you to be able to do it in net
and I also wanted to create building
blocks so common useful classes that if
you're building a audio application in
net you'd be able to piece them together
and make your application so my evenings
I got started and I worked my way
through some initial features like audio
playback and recording I got working I
gave it the ability to read and write
some of the most common audio file
formats so the WAV file format some of
you all know about in the midi file
format if any of you
musicians um I had read and write
support for those and I also really
wanted as I said to be able to play mp3s
because that's what everybody's music
collection ction was
in um but a couple of years after that I
got a new job um started working for a
company called nice um I'm still there
um almost 20 years later so I think that
says it is actually quite a nice place
to work but nice were actually about to
embark on creating a brand new
application called nice in form which
was an incident reconstruction
application for use in public safety so
for example the police might have lots
of recordings of 999 calls and
recordings of police um radio
conversations as well as things like um
dash cam videos and they wanted to piece
it all together on on a timeline and to
play it
back all in synchronization and it
occurred to me this was this was the
moment for n audio and so I volunteered
let me be the one to make the audio
playback engine for this application and
although my vision for n audio had
always been about music that was kind of
my passion and my hobby I love doing a
bit of home studio recording and I
wanted an audio to enable people
musicians to write code um actually a
lot of the things I needed for this
voice-based application were very
similar to what you might need in a
digital audio workstation so I had to
implement things like variable speed
playback um there was some basic effects
like automatic gain control so if
somebody's talking too quietly
you boost the level um I had to be able
to cope with the fact that the Audio I
was playing wasn't fully downloaded so
it was downloading while you were
playing so you had to kind of
automatically pause and
resume I had to deal with audio and
video synchronization which is
absolutely horrible um I don't know if
anybody has tried to sync two just two
video players when you ask them to
reposition they don't go to where you
ask them they just go somewhere roughly
close and so you spend all your time
then after repositioning trying to get
them back to where they should be audio
actually is much easier to mix because
with audio what you do is you don't if
you've got three things to play you
don't open three instances of the sound
card you basically mix it first so
you've got perfect sample
synchronization and then you send that
audio to the sound card and so n audio
has a 32-bit mixing engine and those of
you who've done a a programming will
know that when you're mixing audio you
want to be using floating Point numbers
so you convert your audio to ia uh
floating Point um numbers and then you
can mix them together it means you've
got lots of headro you won't clip and
you can um reduce the volume if you've
gone over before sending it to the sound
card the sample rate was actually very
low if any of you are into music
recording you'll know that you normally
operate at much higher sample rates but
for telef and voice recording you often
use very low sample rates because it
reduces the bandwidth and human voice is
perfectly intelligible at quite um low
sampling
rates um and I also had to do a bit of
audio visualization drawing wave forms
I've open sourced all of that you can
find that on GitHub um I did it both for
Windows forms and for WPF because they
wanted to redact um bits of audio if it
was going to court and perhaps one of
the most interesting things that this uh
application was used for um was the
investigation into the landing of the
plane on the Hudson River so they took
all of the air traffic control
recordings and the um blackbox
recordings and they pieced it all
together in this program and used the
the net audio engine to work out what
had happened and whether this um pilot
had done the right thing or not I won't
spoil the movie for anyone who's not
watched it now one thing
um to just rewind slightly that I
realized when I offered to put my n
audio code into a commercial program was
that um in most of us I don't has anyone
actually read their contract of
employment so lot well done if you have
but somewhere in there it probably says
something like any code that you write
uh we think about while you're working
for us belongs entirely to us and I
realized that um this could be a problem
if I just stuck all of the N audio code
and although n audio in my mind was an
open source application because I had a
um Source Forge page for it and I
couldn't work out how to use CVS at all
that completely confused me but
occasionally I uploaded um zip files of
builds I'd done I realized it needed to
be a bit more of a proper project and
fortunately Microsoft had come out with
codeplex now sadly dead which was an
open source hosting platform that
Windows programmers could actually
understand how to use which was nice um
and so I put an audio onto coplex and I
gave it a license Microsoft decided that
none of the open source licenses were
good enough and they would make up their
own and so I gave it the Microsoft
public license which is a commercially
friendly license and so that meant it
could be taken into a closed Source um
commercial project it's I've now moved
to GitHub and MIT licensing for it
so that's let me just check how we're
doing for time that's a bit of a story
about how the N audio project came to be
by the way going on to coplex was one of
the best things that happened because it
started to give the project more
visibility and I got some really cool
contributions I'll hopefully have a
chance uh to mention a couple of
them but let's uh shift gears a bit now
and start talking about what it's like
to do audio programming in c and onlet
and what are some of the challenges and
the first first thing that I had to do
tons and tons of was platform invoke so
basically reading C++ header files for
all of the windows apis and working out
how to call them in net have any of you
done any P invoke okay well done it's
it's can be quite painful but for those
of you who've never done it before what
you do is you basically tell net there
is a native implementation of this
function so this example exle is wave in
get Dev caps so I'm asking what are the
capabilities of this recording
device and I use the extern keyword to
say it's in an external Library the dll
import attribute is saying that it's in
the win mm dll and then for all of the
parameters and return types you have to
basically work out what is the
equivalent net type that matches this
and so often in C they're they're using
multiple layers of um hash defines so
you have to say well what is a w param
or an L param or a dword eventually you
work out how many bytes it is and you
put ins um for four bite um four bite
integers um one of the mistakes I made
early on is that I I was quite lazy with
interchanging int pointer with int
because everything was 32 bit back then
of course when 64-bit Windows became a
thing everything broke and I had to make
sure I was using in pointer correctly uh
everywhere um but often you have
structures so C programmers love their
structures and so um you have to create
your own equivalent uh structure so here
we've got a wave in caps
structure and what you can do you can
actually use structs or classes in C
they'll both work um but you have to lay
out your structure exactly as the c um
structure is laid out and in fact this
attribute which is struck layout
sequential is telling net you can't mess
with how you store this in memory it has
to be exactly like this because native
code is going to be reading out of it
and possibly even writing into it so
it's got to be laid out exactly right
also if there's any c C++ programmers
around here you'll know that there's
many ways of dealing with strings and so
whenever you've got a string there's
often an extra attribute you have to
fill in to say this is how this string
is going to be passed around is it a
pointer to a string is it a wide string
um is it just a block of bites um that
the string is allowed to be in and might
not even have an old Terminator um that
kind of
thing so I did tons and tons of
that the next big challenge um is
garbage
collection
and on the whole I've only got good
things to say about garbage collection
inet it just works it's really fast it's
uses a very clever algorithm called a
generational Mark and sweep algorithm
but it introduces two big problems for
audio programming and the first problem
is the way that the garbage collector
Works in net is that every now and then
not under your control it will decide to
stop your application and by stop I mean
all of your thread stop so none of your
code is running then it will look at all
of the memory that's been allocated and
it will decide if any of it can be freed
it will free it and then it's also
allowed to move stuff around so it can
compact things and as I say it's very
efficient and fast it doesn't always do
a full collection sometimes it just like
a partial collection to make it quick um
but the problem is if you want to do low
latency audio this can be a real pain
and by low latency um what I mean is
Imagine I've got my midi keyboard here
and I want to press press a note I want
to immediately hear a sound I don't want
to push down the note and then half a
second later I hear a sound that would
make it almost impossible to play and
the way that low latency is achieved
basically you give small buffers of
audio to the sound card very regularly
so maybe 10 milliseconds sometimes it's
smaller than that um but you might give
the sound cards here's 10 milliseconds
of audio to play and while it's playing
it you make the next 10 millisecond
buffer and if you ever Miss
giving it a buffer you'll hear popping
or crackling sounds in the audio and you
certainly don't want that in live
performance so the fact that the garbage
collector might get in and steal some of
your 10 milliseconds is a really big
deal if you want to achieve low latency
um of course not every application does
need low latency there's some
applications where it's it's not a big
deal to have let's say half a second of
of latency so it's not always a
problem the other problem is the
compaction if I've given some native
code a pointer to a memory address and
then that Mo the garbage color moves it
you're going to get a very nasty crash
um so what are the solutions to these
problems um the solution to the pauses
you can't really stop the the garbage
collector from working but what you can
do is do your best to write allocation
free code so if you're using buffers in
particular pre-allocate your buffers
don't create a new buffer every time but
have a few buffers that you've
pre-allocated you fill them and then you
reuse them as the sound card gives it
back to
you of course if you've got a user
interface on your application that it's
kind of tough luck um win forms WPF
they're allocating memory all the time
um so there will be uh garbage
collections happening um in terms of the
um
compaction there's two ways that you can
do it one is you can um pin managed
objects you can tell the garbage
collector you are not allowed to move
this object and it won't move it um or
you can just decide you know what I'm
not even going to ask um net to give me
this memory I'm going to ask the
operating system so you can you can use
native memory so just to quickly show
you a couple of techniques that you can
use for pinning um things first um C is
actually got two very rarely used
keywords the unsafe and fixed keywords
unsafe does a very good job of scaring
most programmers away from using it but
if you use an unsafe key keyword you can
have a fixed block where you actually
get a pointer to a bite array and then
it will not move in memory but you can
also do um casting which is very useful
and hopefully we'll talk about it again
shortly um but fix the fixed block isn't
always suitable sometimes you need
something to be pinned for even longer
and so you can use the GC handle class
to add allocate a pinned handle and that
basically tells the garbage collector
you're not allowed to move this until I
free it
later if you want to do use native
memory then the Marshall class in net is
really useful it's got lots of helpful
methods you can basically allocate some
memory from the operating system and
just get a pointer to it and then you
can use methods like structure to
pointer and there's also pointer to
structure where you can copy from from a
c structure into a native pointer and
vice versa and so that is another way of
getting pointers to things that are not
going to move of course if you do that
you must remember to free memory just
like if you're a c or C++ programmer
otherwise you'll get memory leaks in
your
application okay another interesting
question that came up several times in N
audio was whether I should try to Port
um code from other languages to C or
whether I should just write interop and
that particularly is the case when
you're thinking about digital signal
processing maybe some complicated
algorithms like Fast fer
transforms um but also especially with
codecs so MP3 encoding and decoding AAC
um all of these different codecs there's
often absolutely tons of code and
complexity involved in implementing the
codec
so I certainly wasn't going to do it
myself and the choice is whether as I
say whether you do interrup to a dll
that's got it something like lib faac or
um even FFM Peg or something like that
or whether you try and get all of the
code into
c one of the advantages of the interrupt
approach is it's typically a lot less
work the amount of code you have to
write is way
less um theoretically maybe it runs FAS
I'm not sure this isn't necessarily true
anymore but at least the dll that you've
been given has been optimized to a high
degree and so you've only got the
marshalling overhead of actually calling
into it um it's much much easier to keep
up to date so if you take the trouble to
Port a code base to C and then the next
week they do surprise is a new version
um having to P all of the changes is a
real pain in the
neck um and and it also helps you just
avoid porting bugs I've spent far more
time than I wished I had in my career
porting code between different languages
and you often find very subtle bugs can
get in particularly with things like bit
bit shifting bit manipulation um the
syntax can be exactly the same between
two languages but the implementation can
be different like what happens to the
sign bit as you move things across um so
it's nice to just avoid that but of
course the big downside is it can't run
everywhere it can only run on the
platforms that support that you've got a
binary for and so the advantage the big
advantage of porting an algorithm is
that you've got fully managed code that
is portable it can run on any operating
system um back in the early days I I
used silver light a lot I thought Silver
light was great and I could use the bits
of n audio that didn't use P invoke in
silver light also found a number of
people using an audio using Unity which
I've never built anything in but they're
targeting IOS and Android and so they
can't use anything um that I've just
done rappers for Windows apis so again
having things native is really
useful and just as an example I needed
resampling in N audio for a number of
problems where you're converting audio
from one sample rate to another and at
first I thought I could just do my own
algorithm
um that turned out to be a mistake you
actually need to know a bit about
digital signal processing to do it well
um so I started making wrappers Windows
has got several apis that let you um
wrap that let you do resampling the
audio compression manager direct Tex and
managed objects media Foundation
transforms so I did all of those um
because different skools of Windows like
Windows Server will have one but not the
other and windows um I don't support
Windows XP anymore but you know I
supported many versions of Windows over
the
years
um but then I started to think well
maybe I can Port somebody else's
algorithm and the big trouble that you
run into is licensing almost all of the
good audio code out there on the
internet is GPL or lgpl which is not
compatible with the N audio license
eventually I found um a resampler by a
company called cockos who make the
reaper digital audio workstation which
is the one I use and I got in touch with
them and they were okay with me porting
it so I had a fully managed resampler in
the
end okay let's talk about Windows audio
apis I kind of feel like I know way more
than I wish I did about all the windows
audio apis but Microsoft
have many apis for audio the first one
is whenn m M and wimm has been in
Windows since the very early days was in
there since
1991 and if you've seen any of the apis
that begin with wave in wave out and
there's some midi ones there's mixer
ones um they're they've they've all been
been in there for ages they're all still
supported you can still use them they
work absolutely fine uh they are
unfortunately High latency so you're not
going to be able to do live music
performances with them you you can't
really get below 50 milliseconds at at
the lowest with them um but those were
the first ones I did and actually
probably the wrappers I've made for
those are still the widest used um I did
run into a number of problems that it
gives you a choice of callback methods
so when the sound card tells you that
it's finished playing a buffer of audio
you can choose for it to directly call a
function um which sounded a great idea
but I realized that you've got to be
super careful what you do in that
function or you'll get a deadlock um and
you can get posted a Windows message
which was much more reliable but then it
forced everyone to take a dependency on
Wind forms which not everyone liked um
but you can also use mutexes so you can
wait on a mutex and that's actually the
best way and the way that I recommend
people use an
audio but then in 2007 Microsoft decided
to break everything and reinvent
everything with Windows uh with Vista to
um Windows Vista and there was a
complete refresh of the audio stack so I
think waspp is the Windows audio
subsystem API and it was a it's a
massive sprawling API it's got hundreds
of things in it I haven't I still
haven't finished writing rappers for all
of it uh it's also a com based
API which brings some interesting
headaches of its own particularly about
threading if you create an object on one
thread and then try and use it on
another thread depending on what type of
object it is it will not work um but it
had the the concept of exclusive mode or
shared mode so when I'm playing audio I
can say I either want to share the sound
code sound card with other um other
programs or I want exclusive access and
if I've got exclusive access then I can
have much lower
latency it also had um it also basically
when it initially came out you had to
give it audio as floating Point samples
and you had to give it audio at whatever
the sample rate the sound card happened
to be at so if somebody had just watched
a DVD you had to give it 48 khz audio
and if they just played a CD you had to
give it 44.1 and that was really
annoying because um it had no resampler
it does have a resampler now but that's
why I needed a resampler for n audio to
cope with this
um it's also got some other nice
features like loot back capture so you
can record the audio that's being played
by your system while it's being played
um and so was zappi actually is probably
now the way I recommend that you you use
uh n audio but it's only recently really
that it's become better choice for most
people than win
mm then in 2016 Microsoft decided to
make yet another audio API and this was
for the universal windows platform it's
called audiograph and what's cool about
this one is it's already
allnet um objects so you can directly
without having to do wrapper layer you
can use audiograph in
net and I was quite excited about this I
made a plural site course about it that
um I thought was really good but
absolutely nobody watched it and um it's
got a graph-based
API um and I actually think that's the
best way to design an API for audio
programming the concept of a graph where
you're connecting things together
um I would say it's the best I it had
potential to replace in audio because
many of the things in audio can do
audiograph can do it has one fatal
limitation and that is you cannot make a
node that transforms
audio that um does an effect the only
way you can do an effect is you have you
have to make a a com object separate
project Implement a com object and then
load that into your other program which
is just a pain in the neck so I really
hope they fix that at some point um
but I'm not using it because of that
limitation the final one I want to
mention is not a Microsoft One um and
that's asio anybody familiar with that
maybe if you do music recording you will
know that anyone who is um doing large
music or music recording will not use
any of the windows apis because they're
all unreliable and dodgy and this um
interface created by Steinberg in
97 is the best for absolute super low
latency if you want to get the minimal
latency and you've bought a nice sound
card um AIO is great for that and one of
the cool things about being an open
source project is every now and then
someone will contribute something that's
really good and somebody contributed a
wrau AO into an audio which I think is
brilliant um it's a little bit um
different the way it works in that
record and Playback are together in AO
so um they're not treated as separate
devices and that's actually good if
you're recording because you want to
synchronize you want to know that th
this um while I was listening to the
backing track and I played this on my
guitar It lines up exactly here so AIO
works really well for that
okay
so I talked about um when I mentioned
the audio graph that that is I think a
good way of doing um an audio API um but
what is the um fundamental way that we
should design audio apis and I've
already hinted at this that with audio
we're often connecting things together
into signal chains we've got a guitar
that produces some sound we plug it into
one effect we plug that into another we
go to our amplifier and in audio
programming it can actually be more
complicated than that we might have
multiple things that are producing sound
so I might have a microphone and I might
also have a pre-recorded file I might
put an effect on the microphone so
actually transforming the sound as it
passes through like Reverb or I might
not be transforming it I might be doing
visualization so I might want to draw a
volume meter or a
waveform um but then we want to mix our
audio together um and then you might
actually send it to multiple outputs so
you might send it to a sound card and
you might also write it to a file you
might send it over the network stream it
or something um and so n audio tries to
enable you to do this and we won't have
time to go into all of the um API of n
audio but probably the two most
important interfaces to understand the
audio graph are the I wave provider and
the I sample
provider now now iWave provider is
basically saying I can give you audio
data and so I need two things if you can
give me audio data I need to know what
format your audio is in is it mono or
stereo what sample rate is it are you
using integer bit uh samples are you
using um floating point maybe you're
still compressed maybe it's like an AAC
file so that's what the wave format
property is for but then the read method
is just saying I want to read a number
of btes of audio out of the Stream into
my buffer and I'm sure if your net
programmers you all have used streams
and this is exactly how streams work a
file stream a network stream any stream
um can you has a read method that lets
you read into a buffer so it's
essentially taking the same
idea however if you've done any audio
programming you'll know you don't really
want bite eras you want to get at the
samples and samples can be in they can
be 16bit they can
24 bits sometimes um but really if you
want to do digital signal processing or
mixing you want floating Point samples
and so I sample provider is exactly the
same thing but you've get you're getting
floating Point samples and so that makes
it much easier for you to um work on
them so my recommendation with n audio
is to get a sample provider as fast as
you can and then do all of your
processing um that you need to do and N
audio tries to help help you with this
there's a number of classes that kind of
try and get you pretty much straight
there now one of the Troubles of going
from a biter rate to a um floater rate
is that casting and this is very
difficult in CP so if I have a bite
array that's got some audio in it and
actually I know that really in that bite
array are floating Point numbers you
cannot just cast it to a floating a
float array that will not compile
and so I was looking for a solution for
this for an audio because I wanted to
cast because that's fast but Net's not
going to let me do it so one of the
options is to use that unsafe and fixed
keyword so that is how I initially did
it it does
work but it puts off a lot of
programmers a lot of people don't feel
confident doing that in their code and
understanding how to do it so I was also
looking for other ways you can um copy
things around so you can say okay I've
got a bite array and I'm going to move
everything over into float array of
course that's a performance problem you
don't really want to do that and then
came another genius slightly mad genius
um contribution to n audio which was
what's called The Wave
buffer and the wave buffer
basically uses a trick in net that is
designed for when you're using unions uh
where you're doing interrupt to unions
and C++ is anyone familiar with what a
union is so in C++ it's very common in
your structure to say at this memory
address there might be one of these or
there might be one of those or there
might be something else and the way that
you represent that in net is you say
that I've got an explicit structure and
that I'm going to tell you the exact
address or the exact offset in the
structure of every member and what you
can do is therefore you can put several
things at the same offset so you can
tell net that at the same offset in my
structure same memory address there's a
bite array and a float array and a short
array it turns out if you do this you
can write into the bite array and you
can read out of the float array and I
was a bit scared I did not believe this
is going to work it has worked
flawlessly for 20 years um and basically
it gives me casting um there's one weird
Quirk that if you ask if you try and ask
the float array how long you are it
won't it'll be confused about how long
it is so but apart from that it it
works and so n audio is based on this
little trick that saves us copying
memory or having to always go to fixed
blocks however if only there was
something called span if only this had
existed a long time ago have any of you
used span of T um this is I can't
remember when it came in it was in
fairly early in net core but 3.1 yeah
and this is this is perfect this is what
we've needed forever basically I could
have I could change my wave provider and
Sample provider to just say read into a
span of bite and what a span is
basically it's saying I don't care
whether the the actual memory backing
this is managed memory from um net or
native memory from the operating system
I just want to be able to read in and
out of it like it's an an array it's
also got length built in which is really
convenient and you can slice them so you
don't have to have pass around all those
length and offset parameters that you
have to with
streams and it supports casting which is
absolutely brilliant so I can be given a
span of btes and I can say actually I
know that this has got floating Point
numbers in it so you can using the
memory marshall. cast you can um cast it
so that's brilliant I actually created
in the N audio GitHub repository there
is a branch where I've converted n audio
to span uh I did it a number of years
back and I kind of put it out there to
the community what do you think and the
vb.net people said oh we can't use span
um which surprised me I kind of imagined
that you could do everything in in
vb.net that you could in C but it kind
of ended up getting parked a little bit
it would be quite a big breaking change
but if I were ever to kind of do a n
audio version three I think um span
would make much more sense and in fact
um net has made many strides forward
since the early days when I started on
NET Framework we now have net core which
is now just net um I love the fact that
there's so much focus on performance it
is much faster and therefore it's
becoming a much better platform for
audio programming um and also the fact
that it's crossplatform so you can use n
audio on Linux just don't try and call
Windows apis because they're not there
um there's also much better support for
things like function pointers you've got
control over the actual Intermediate
Language that you emit which is really
useful if you're doing some com interop
and the ilil that it emits isn't quite
what you want um and we're also starting
to see a lot of code generation
approaches to platform invoke um so
there's a new library import attribute
that replaces dll import and will code
gen the marshalling code for you
um and there's a library that Microsoft
are maintaining of interrupt rappers
although in some ways I kind of prefer
my handrolled interrupt rappers because
you can choose the types that are most
make most sense for your use case so
sometimes the Cen ones aren't actually
very
helpful so can you use let me just check
how much how we're doing for time we're
okay can you use uh net for audio
absolutely yes you can um I've shown you
my n audio project which I've used to
build a lot of things but I also had
contact with lots of other people who
built all kinds of stuff um I've got a
fully managed MP3 decoder I've built one
of the things I made was a Skype voice
changer that would intercept the audio
and Skype calls and change your voice uh
put silly effects on sadly it doesn't
work anymore but that is open source um
I made a midi file mapping tool that if
you've got drum beats that are designed
for one sample it converts them over to
another sampler um I've actually built
several commercial products for voice
and telep recording using net
um but maybe the slightly sad ending to
this talk is the fact that um I started
n audio over 2002 how many years ago is
that over 20 years ago and it was a fun
hobby project I was enjoying it I was I
was doing it for fun but you know life
circumstances change and I think a
number of Open Source projects in the
net Community are going through this um
situation where maybe their original
maintainers haven't got the time to work
on them anymore and certainly I found
that although I'm still doing audio
programming um I'm not typically doing
it in net as much as I was I'm doing it
in other languages dsls for audio
programming or JavaScript and so on and
so I haven't actually had the need to
work on na audio as much so I would say
that n audio is no longer under active
development I do fix bugs I do accept
PRS I do answer questions almost every
day but I'm not really working a lot on
adding new features to it and so it is
open to new maintainers so if that's
something that does interest you I'd be
very happy to have a chat but I think we
have time for a very short
demo so let
me
unplug
this
and
okay so let me just check what you can
see you see visual
studio um don't worry about not being
able to see the code basically this
program um what it does is it's first of
all it's asking what audio devices have
I got and I'm actually using this Roland
Groove box as a sound card and so I'm
going to
pick that and then it's also going to
ask what midi devices have I got and
I've got this little mini midi keyboard
so it's going to listen to U midi
messages that are being sent from this
midi device and um what it will do is
that when I press a key on here it will
receive a midi message it will then use
a synthesizer entirely written in um C
to synthesize a sound based on a file
format called a sound font um this the
synthesizer isn't my work it's somebody
else's project called melty synth that
integrates really nicely within audio
and so if I press the key on here
hopefully we will hear
some sounds if I press these drum pads
they're
sending messages on
um on channel 10 which in MIDI
convention means they're going to be
drum sounds rather than Note sounds and
I can even play MIDI files so if I press
a key here oh yeah you're seeing
hopefully you're seeing it's reporting
the midi messages that it's receiving as
we're getting them if I press the space
bar it will actually load a midi file
and it will play the midi file through
the C sequencer so let's start that up
make sure it's not too
[Music]
loud
okay so that is that is my talk on um
audio programming Inn net um it's
something I'm quite passionate about so
i' be very glad to chat with any of you
further but did anyone want to take ask
any questions I don't know how much time
we got
left yep let me
just
yeah
you could so you could take you know
obviously none of the P invoke stuff
would make any sense but you could take
the um you
know the classes in N audio that deal
with file formats and deal with um
resampling and various codecs that are
fully managed and you could call them
the only thing I say is like what
exactly would be the point because
actually the J the browser audio is
really quite good um you can find a lot
of um I've been playing a lot with the
um web audio things like tone JS do what
n audio can do and a lot more um with
wasm um if any of you have used V VST
plugins and synthesizers you can
actually compile those to um wasm and
load them in the browser and there's
some amazing demos of that and so I
think um audio in the browser is really
going places um but I don't really see
that n AIO contributes an awful lot
unless you love C and you want to be
always in the world of c um but yeah
there's I can recommend the audio
developers conference you can get an
online ticket for that fairly cheaply
it's happening later this year and um
lots of really exciting stuff happening
in the audio space in
WM
yeah net Maui okay so I haven't done a
lot of Mary Carl Franklin who's here and
I think he's talking about Mari has
tried to do some audio stuff in Mary and
he was he got in touch with me and he
was like oh can we can we kind of use it
an audio with Mari and what you find
often in these apis is that the the
audio playback support is play this
file and if you want to produce your own
samples and give it to it that isn't
isn't good enough and when I looked into
it not too long ago we did not let you
just give give it samples you had to
give it a file stream and so
unfortunately again you could use bits
of an audio in Mari um but you can't do
the really fun stuff like I just showed
there you couldn't do that because it
doesn't give you the ability to inject
your own samples to directly to the
sound
card
yeah I mean n Audia has got interfaces
it's got an iWave player and it's got an
iWave in so you can Implement those for
other platforms I don't I think some
people have actually done that but
they're not part of n audio itself um
but on Mari I don't even know how you
would do it because it's it's just
not okay yeah that's a good idea
yeah yes so you kind of make a shim for
an audio to send audio out through the
web audio API yeah that's a good idea
great any other
questions if not thank you very
[Applause]
much